>> Welcome back!
What you just got was 88.4% correct for Naive Bayes.
>> 88.4% !
Awesome guys.
>> Well, does that mean that your,
your self-driving car only crashed 11.6% of the time?
>> It'll crash occasionally yeah.
It's not good enough for cars.
>> Okay. >> But it's great for this course.
>> It is very good.
It's much better than guessing.
One of the things that you did in that example,
maybe you didn't even realized you were doing it was you trained and
you tested on two different sets of data.
>> And that's actually really important in machine learning we always train and
test on different data.
>> If you don't do that what can happen is that you can overfit to your
training data.
You can think that you know better what's going on than you actually know.
>> That's really important because in machine learning you have to kind of
generalize to new data that's somewhat different.
An algorithm would just memorize all the data,
test it on the same data as training data, which will always give you 100%.
But it had no clue how to generalize to new data.
>> That's right. So what you should always do,
and what we'll always do in this course,
is you should save maybe 10% of your data and you use it as your testing set.
And that's what you use to actually tell you how much progress you're
making in terms of learning your patterns in your data.
>> So, when you report the results to yourself and to your boss or
your client, use the test results, because it's much better,
fair kind of understanding of how well you are doing with you training data.